today's the day hashtag secret project
starts now
the secret project is not too deep with
grace helbig an audio / video podcasts
I'm so sorry
yes it's an audio and video podcast how
does that work I know let me explain it
to you you must be very very confused
here's how it's going to work in the
videos here on this YouTube channel such
a great channel you'll be seeing little
snippets from the interview that I do
with each of my guests the interviews
like the title not too deep I don't need
to know [ __ ] about these people well
some I want to know about when they Shh
but I don't want to know the deep about
them cool but if you want to listen to
the audio interview in its entirety you
can subscribe to our podcast not too
deep with grace Helbig on itunes on
soundcloud on other places but those are
probably the two easiest places for you
to do it you can go right now
go great job or do it later if you chose
that as a path anyway this video will
contain portions of the interview and
then a lovely YouTube game that I have
created because I've been inspired by
the really stupid challenges that exist
on YouTube and I decided to make them
stupider and play them with my guest who
is my first guest you might ask I'm
pretty sure the title says it already
but it's the one and only queen of the
internet Tyler Oakley
and I get you you get me yeah cuz I feel
like you get me I get you yeah yeah I
mean the shirt alone get my [ __ ] yeah
like that is an ice cream sweater yeah I
eat it is me in a sweatshirt there's a
cream sweatshirt give us three words
that are associated with your worst
pants King story University mm-hmm
dripping oh and uh I winter Oh
so I wasn't completely bundled up
because it was winter Oh got it
oh you don't have to tell me the story I
can imagine I'll let the listeners at
home it was a moment words together I
trusted the fart never trust hot that's
on my tombstone like that famous last
words
I trust the fire okay the red maff
Raqqah if he woke up one day with a
juice box what would he do with it I
drink it all though but you don't know
where this juice box came right and my
stepmom would always warn me like you
never know you could be sucking through
a juice box and a worm could come up and
I always think that now my god my
parents have messed me up okay where's
you step on like a crazy witch like a
worm I am up and I'm also scared of like
cereal boxes that there's ants in them I
I don't know where these all come from
it's literally from my childhood my
parents that's the crazy thing to me
about having kids that you can just tell
your boyish things though you can tell
them any reality I don't know I can't
drink out a juice box if I ever had a
child which I don't think is ever
happening for me in my life but I'm the
first phrase I want them to learn how to
say is I'm reincarnated Danny Bianco if
you were drag queen what would your
stage name be and what would your
routine be like well have it all planned
out okay so my drag name would be pre me
fatuus spelled fetus like a premature
fetus and I would still have my own bill
Cory and I would do a little bit of this
like we're like a lasso and I would have
one of those what do you call them like
a suck on a pacifier yep
and I would you have a pacifier in a
diaper and every in if you're ever gonna
spell out my name every single letter
has an accent because every letter is
important preemie fuh tus you're fine
are we looking account no well let's see
okay take your blindfold off
wait I won't be able to see as soon as I
think I know I'm gonna give you your
glasses cuz I'm blind
okay yes over your eyes welcome we are
the cameras on hi welcome to your
challenge Tyler this part of not too
deep with your so big I take a normal
YouTube challenge and I make it stupid
so you have done the Edward forty hands
channel I have today we're going to do
the Edwards forty hands challenge oh
we're going to be duct taping a baseball
to each hand and while we're duct-taped
to the baseball's our challenge is to
eat a hot dog open and chug a beer eat
one peanut and then get to the prize in
the box of caramel corn this is the best
challenge I've ever done I know thank
you and you're welcome okay so first
things first we're gonna do is get
ourselves a duct tape okay oh my god so
here we go
on your mark no I'm not really that
ready okay get yourself ready I'm
nervous
on your mark get set go that's
impossible
Oh oh my god oh here's what I really
want you know
no hair on my mouth oh my god I've never
felt cuter what are you going why are
you so well you look so cute
can you like look at the beers you
drinking it it's like you
I am you shut up you how do you get the
man oh it's Tyler Oakley you officially
the Edwardsport II have my entire life
has led up to this moment my mom is so
proud yeah Jackie I'd like to thank this
year I know good sorry it's on you
it's okay how do you got peanut on your
nose that was fun that was really fun
Tyler okay thank you for being here I
should let you go over to iTunes and
subscribe to the podcast so you can hear
the full interview wait you really
should it's funny and go over and
subscribe to Toto play on youtube and if
you're one of my people subscribe to
grace cuz she's my favorite excuse me
thanks for watching
I don't know wow remember my hair look
like that yeah we shot these a decent
amount of time ago years and years in
the internet world anyway if you want to
go listen to the podcast and its
entirety go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
search rush we did with grace Helbig and
subscribe and listen he says a lot of
really amazing stuff that he can't take
back go check it out